[Music]  katie kirk's in the news she's launching  her new daytime show next week and uh to  build excitement producers have been  releasing a series of get to know katie  videos uh here's one i found  particularly insightful  ever since i was a little kid like even  four or five i would sit on the piano  bench and kind of  i could figure out songs  [Music]  i came to understand that i could play  piano by ear  [Music]  it's pretty easy to play in a key of c  [Music]  and  it gives me a lot of joy it really does  i don't have the heart to tell her no  one does  no one has for years what's so hard  about this  and every holiday she's like oh all  right i'll play no you really don't have  to oh no no no i can tell  that's fine katie no more we're good  [Laughter]